i want to kind of close the loop on that
explosive story from last week
last week i notified you that there is
another call that now is playing a role
in the investigation taking place in
georgia another call
in which donald trump called the
investigator
in the secretary of state's office in
georgia again to talk about i need a
couple thousand votes and
there was a lot of wrongdoing and we won
by a lot and we won this by a lot and
all of these different statements
that call which we learned about last
week we have now
learned was found in a
trash folder on the computer device
of a state investigator which raises new
questions
about whether there was an effort made
to actually
suppress the fact that that phone call
took place
cnn reports that discovery of the call
came after state officials originally
said
they didn't think audio of the call
existed
and it turns out that it did exist it
was in the trash
folder of an investigator involved in
this
and it is the uh recording in which
trump
pushes on the investigator francis
watson
uh claims of widespread voter fraud and
uh trying to influence the investigation
and subsequently really trying to
overturn the results in georgia so that
the electoral votes in georgia would go
to trump instead of to joe biden
the audio file is from a december 23
call
we listened to it last week and the call
is between
trump and investigator francis watson
it was discovered as the georgia
secretary of state's office was
responding to a public records request
the washington post first reported the
details
of how the audio emerged watson was
asked
did you delete this why did you delete
it why was it in that folder
it was uncovered only due to a foia
request did you plan to come forward and
say this exists because
there's a big difference if you're an
investigator between saying
hey i have this call versus
hitting delete and relegating it to your
recycle bin presumably for future
deletion now of course
we could say you know if she really
meant to eliminate the record
she would have cleared the recycle bin i
assume that by
a full a folder of deleted files they're
talking about a recycle bin or
equivalent
it's all very very strange and cnn
previously reported
that in that december phone call that's
at issue trump was
urging her to find ways to give him
georgia and saying she would be praised
if she were able to overturn those
results
and uh we now are going to have to see
what the the meaning and significance is
of this
last week the bombshell was the call
trump made to brad raffensberger
wasn't the only call to georgia
officials before the call to brad
raffensberger trump actually called
francis watson and said much of the same
which is wow this so now we know
this was not a one-off call this was a
series of scheduled phone calls
now we learn that we learned of the
audio
because of a foia request and it was in
a deleted files folder on frances
watson's computer
which starts to change maybe the course
of this investigation where
maybe the investigators actually need to
be investigated so it's getting
increasingly complex include
increasingly muddied and and
i asked this question i'm not saying
this rhetorically
are there investigators in georgia
that can actually really investigate
this objectively
um the you know brad raffensberger's
office the secretary of state
they're clearly not the right place
because they are participants in all of
this brad raffensberger was the one
trump called to try to influence on the
results
so we know about investigator francis
watson but now we learned francis watson
had deleted audio of the call
and it was in the recycle bin or
something equivalent to it so
that's probably not the right person to
investigate how it ended up there so so
who exactly
needs to be brought in do you need some
kind of special investigator
do federal authorities need to come in
do they would they have jurisdiction i
don't know
uh but this needs to be figured out
because this is just georgia
but every week we are learning more that
makes
that raises more questions rather than
answering them
about exactly how um uh planned
and uh coordinated was this effort to
try to overturn the georgia results
there's also now
emails that have come out referencing
upcoming phone calls with donald trump's
then chief of staff mark meadows
in georgia which again suggests the
phone calls were happening
the phone calls involving trump were
happening after other
preparatory phone calls were already
made this may have may
been a much larger effort to after the
fact try to steal georgia from joe biden
hopefully we'll we'll learn the full
scope of it at some point in time
we're going to take a quick break
stunning video from senator ron johnson
coming up
after the break uh and we will also talk
about this is strange
the announcement of urination on fox
news i know it sounds crazy but we'll
talk about it after the break